Yeah.
Okay.
So you're,
you're weaving a number of things together.
So the first is your discovery that if you look at the data,
that things are getting better at a rate that's so remarkable that it is really
nothing short of miraculous.
And you've produced dozens of graphs showing that in enlightenment.
Now,
I noticed the same thing about three years ago when I was working for a UN panel
on economic sustainability.
The writ for the,
for the secretary general,
the original narrative was extremely pessimistic and detailed how we were
destroying the planet and how everything was getting works and how we were at,
uh,
at each other's throats.
And I started to read extremely widely and I found that on measure after measure
with some notable exceptions like ocean oceanic overfishing,
we have been doing so staggeringly much better in the last hundred and 50 years
that you can't believe it on almost every,
on almost every measure you can imagine,
which is exactly what you detail out and enlightenment now.
And,
and then now that that's a secret,
let's say people don't know about it.
And Yeah,
and that's strange.
And then you also associated with a critique of the,
of,
of the enlightenment and scientific rationality.
And it seems to me that you're implying,
or perhaps you're stating explicitly that
you're,
you're stating explicitly that there's a connection between the pessimism and
the lack of knowledge about this and the critique of the enlightenment and
rationality.
Because there's a question here.
If things are getting so much better and if the news is overwhelming on that
front,
I mean,
some of the things you outlined are like the weather,
the decrease decreases in starvation I suppose are the most remarkable.
And the provision of bountiful food on less and less far bunt,
which is not something that people don't.
It's like,
if all this is happening,
why don't we know about it?
And how is it linked to the,
how do you think if,
if it all is linked to the critique of,
of enlightenment rationality,
what are the reasons?
Is,
uh,
an interaction between the nature of journalism and the nature of cognition?
They,
we,
uh,
the news is about what happens,
not what hasn't happened.
And a lot of the,
uh,
very beneficial developments consist of things that don't happen.
Countries that are at peace,
that used to be
kids who are not starving.
Um,
a kit,
uh,
terrorist attacks that do not happen.
You never see a journalist saying,
I'm reporting live from a country that's been at peace for 40 years.
But if a war breaks out,
you can be sure that we'll hear about it all the more.
So now that to a majority of humanity consists of,
uh,
on the spot video.
Journalists thanks to smart phones,
uh,
also,
bad things can happen quickly.
Things can blow up,
worst can start,
a massacre can happen,
but good things aren't built in a day.
And they often consist of incremental improvements with few percentage points a
year that the compound that that accumulate.
But that can never make the news because they never happened all of a sudden on
a Thursday in October.
But together with all the,
the,
um,
cognitive impediments to understanding the state of the world,
the fact that news reports memorable events.
And we know,
uh,
from the,
study of the cognition of risk and probability from Daniel Kahneman and Amos
Tversky,
that we tend to assess probability and risk by a shortcut called the
availability heuristic.
Namely,
the easier it is to I dredge up an example from memory,
the more likely we think something is.
And so people think that a tornadoes kill a lot of people,
but they don't realize that falling off ladders kills far more people.
I just,
cause when someone falls off a ladder,
it doesn't make the news.
But when there is a tornado it does.
Yeah.
Do you know that solar power kills more people to nuclear power every a year?
I did not know that,
but it doesn't surprise me because nuclear power kills no one,
I suppose as installers fall off,
roof installers fall off roofs.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Well,
so,
so that's interesting.
So you can imagine that.
So good news or bad news,
his son is dramatic.
We're,
we're tilted towards the processing of negative information in any case.
Well,
that's right.
We don't naturally computer ratio between,
uh,
occurrences and not occurrences,
which is of course what goes into a probability and rational assessment of risk
and probability.
So there's that,
but it's,
it's more than that than that because in intellectual life,
in large parts of academia and in,
uh,
among commentators and pundits,
there is an ideology of,
uh,
of decline.
It goes back to the 19th century,
uh,
part of the counter enlightenment that arose in a,
as a reaction to enlightenment,
hopes for,
for progress and rationality that said that,
that,
that the holes that society is Western civilization is teetering on the brink or
it's circling,
circling the drain and it's going to collapse,
uh,
any,
any time now.
And it's up to the intellectuals and commentators and,
uh,
to,
point out how decadent to degenerate society is and to people like that musical
progress comes also in a front
there.
The reaction is,
hey,
we've been,
we've been a warning,
all of you about how society is on the verge of collapse.
Don't come around and tell us that if everything's going fine,
we're,
what are we going to do now?
Yeah.
You identify a lot of that with the romantic types like Russo.
And when I was reading,
I wondered to the,
there's a,
there's a powerful Marxists narrative that's run it's course for about 130 years
too.
That's predicated on the idea that there's an oppressed class and the no
pressure class.
And that narrative seems also to thrive on or two to be a fronted by the idea
that the current,
the current system might be producing benefits across the board.
I think you do in fact,
in one part of the book ask about whether or not these benefits are only
accruing,
for example,
to the rich.
And that doesn't seem to be the case as far as,
as far as the data indicates.
Is that a fair,
quite the contrary.
The most dramatic improvements have been at the,
at the bottom among re,
uh,
extreme poor where,
the proportion of the world's population living in extreme poverty,
it's fallen over the last couple of centuries from probably around 90% to less
than 10%.
And the United Nations is,
sends one of it's millennium elegant goals to eliminate extreme poverty
everywhere by the year 2030.
That's probably too optimistic at the fact that it can be set as a,
uh,
as a,
as a plausible aspiration.
Is it self astonishing?
Oh,
I know the UN had said as one of its millennial goals,
the having of absolute poverty between 2000 and 2015 and that was accomplished
by 2012
exactly.
Ahead of schedule.
Yes,
exactly.
And that
Marxism has a,
a,
a complicated relationship to progress because Marxist doctrine actually does,
uh,
layout up pathway to progress.
Unfortunately,
that pathway consists of violet class conflict.
I,
it isn't the enlightenment ideal of progress through,
uh,
through problem solving,
the pro se,
uh,
belief that a nature throws problems at us and that if we applied brain power,
we can gradually chip away at them.
Mentally of progress is quite different.
And you're right that there is a,
a pretty strong,
there are critiques of progress both from the left and from the right,
but from,
from the left,
uh,
there is a,
um,
uh,
kind of contempt for institutions like,
like markets like liberal democracy that deserve a lot of the credit for the
progress that we've made in that would be to,
uh,
at least in the academic left a,
an despising of the very idea of progress.
And I found that that the,
the only political faction is actually sympathetic to progress or libertarians
that have been a number of rational optimist books,
uh,
in the last decade by people like Matt Ridley and Ron Bailey and Johan Norberg
that,
uh,
that do have an overlapping vision to the one that I took on the light light
down and we documenting progress.
Um,
but both from the,
the,
uh,
academic left and from the political right,
there has been a,
uh,
a contempt for the notion of progress or their different reasons in academia.
It goes back to the Romantics too.
So as you mentioned,
but also to Schopenhauer nature.
Heidegger,
the existentialists,
the critical theorists of the Frankfurt school,
large swaths of the academic humanities.
Uh,
actually the test,
the enlightenment,
I ironically enough,
not by no means all of them,
but I have to have,
but there's a significant faction
questionnaire,
kitchen partners.
Why,
I mean one of the things that really struck me as I've gone through this
material over the last years is that this is really good news.
Particularly it doesn't really matter whether you're on the left to the right.
If you're on the left,
you think that the fact that the poorest of the poor are being lifted out of
their abject,
absolute abject misery at a rate that's just,
I don't think you could hope for a faster improvement no matter how optimistic
you work.
And then on the right of course,
the fact that the benefits of liberal democracy,
let's say,
and free markets are driving this in large part,
you'd take would also be a cause for celebration.